next week talking to Christo's Goudreau
I'm not sure of you familiar who he is
but he's the VP of engineering head of
the quote unquote YouTube algorithm this
search and discoveries yeah let me ask
first high-level do you have do you have
a question for him that if you can get
an ounce honest answer that you would
ask but more generally how do you think
about the YouTube algorithm that drives
some of the motivation behind not know
some of the design decisions you make as
you ask and answer some of the questions
you do how would you improve this
algorithm in your mind in general so
just the what would you ask him and
outside of that how would you like to
see the algorithm improve well I think
of the algorithm as a mirror it reflects
what people put in and we don't always
like what we see in that mirror from the
individual mirror to the individual
Meritor of the society both in the
aggregate it's reflecting back what
people on average want to watch and when
you see things being recommended to you
it's reflecting back what it thinks you
want to see and specifically I would
guess that it's not just what you want
to see but what you will click on and
what you will watch some of and stay on
YouTube because of I don't think that is
all me guessing but I don't think that
YouTube cares if you only watch like a
second of a video as long as the next
thing you do is open another video if
you close the app or close the site
that's a problem for them because
they're not a subscription platform
they're not like look you're giving us
20 bucks a month no matter what so who
cares they need you to watch and spend
time there and see ads so one of the
things I'm curious about whether they do
consider longer term sort of develop you
your longer-term development as a human
being which I think ultimately will make
you feel better about using YouTube in
the long term and allowing you to stick
with it
for longer because even if you feed the
dopamine rush in the short-term and you
keep clicking on cat videos the
eventually you can sort of wake up like
from a drug and say I need to quit this
so I wonder how much they're trying to
optimize for the long term because when
I look at the you know your videos
aren't exactly a sort of no offense but
they're not the most clickable they're
both the most clickable and I feel i
watch the entire thing and I feel a
better human after I watched it right so
like they're not for just optimizing for
the click ability is this is I I hope so
my thought is how do you think of it and
does it affect your own content like how
deep you go how profound you explore the
directions and so on I I've been really
lucky in that I don't worry too much
about the algorithm I mean look at my
thumbnails I don't really go too wild
with them and with minefield where I'm
in partnership with YouTube on the
thumbnails I'm often like let's pull
this back let's be mysterious but
usually I'm just trying to do what
everyone else is not doing so if
everyone's doing crazy Photoshop kind of
thumbnails I'm like what if the
thumbnails just align yeah and what if
the title is just a word yeah and I I
kind of feel like all of the Vsauce
channels have cultivated an audience
that expects that and so they would
rather Jake make a video that's just
called staines then one called
I explored stains shocking yeah but
there are other audiences out there that
want that and you know I think most
people kind of you don't want what you
see the algorithm favoring which is
mainstream traditional celebrity and
news kind of information I mean that's
what makes YouTube really different than
other streaming platforms
no one's like what's going on in the
world I'll open up Netflix to find out
but you do open up Twitter to find that
out you open up Facebook you can open up
YouTube because you'll see that the
trending videos are like what happened
amongst the traditional mainstream
people in different industries and
that's what's being shown and it's it's
not necessarily YouTube saying we want
that to be what you see it's that that's
what people click on when they see
ariana grande
day you know reads a love letter from
like her highschool sweetheart they're
like I want to see that and when they
see a video from me that's got some
lines in math and it's called law and
causes they're like won't I mean that
I'm just on the bus like I don't have
time to dive into a whole lesson so you
know before you get super mad at youtube
you should say really they're just
reflecting back human behavior is there
something you would improve about the
algorithm knowing of course that as far
as we're concerned it's a black box so
we don't know how it works right and I
don't think that even anyone at YouTube
really knows what it's doing they know
what they've tweaked but then it learns
I think that it learns and it decides
how to behave and sometimes they're the
YouTube employees are left going I don't
know maybe we should like change the
value of how much it you know worries
about watch time and maybe it should
worry more about something I don't know
but I mean I would like to see I don't
know what they're doing and not doing
well is there a conversation that you
think they should be having just
internally whether they're having it or
not
is there something should they be
thinking about the long-term future
should they be thinking about
educational content and whether that's
educating about what just happened in
the world today news or educational
content like what you're providing which
is asking big timeless questions about
how the way the world works
well it's interesting like what should
they think about because it's called
YouTube not our tube and if that's why I
think they have so many phenomenal
educational creators yes you don't have
shows like three blue one brown or
physics girl or Looking Glass universe
or of an atom or brain scoop or I mean I
could go on and on they aren't on amazon
prime and netflix and it and they don't
have Commission shows from those
platforms it's all organically happening
because there are people out there that
want to share their passion for learning
that want to share their curiosity and
YouTube could you know promote those
kinds of shows more but like first of
all they probably wouldn't get as many
clicks and YouTube needs to make sure
that the average user is always clicking
instead
on the site they could still promote it
more for the good of society but then
we're making some really weird claims
about what's good for society because I
think that cat videos are also an
incredibly important part of what it
means to be a human I've mentioned this
quote before from unamuno about look
I've seen a cat like estimate distances
and calculate a jump you know more often
than I've seen a cat cry and so things
that that play with our emotions and
make us feel things can be cheesy and
can feel cheap but like man that's very
human and so even the dumbest vlog is
still so important that I don't think it
I have a better claim to take its spot
than it has to have that spot so it puts
a mirror to us the beautiful parts the
ugly parts the shallow parts the Jeep
ours
you're right what I would like to see is
you know I I miss the days when engaging
with content on YouTube helped push it
in to my subscribers timelines it used
to be that when I liked a video say from
veritasium it would show up in the feed
on the front page of the app or the
website of my subscribers and I knew
that if I liked a video I could send it
a hundred thousand views or more that no
longer is true but I think that was a
good user experience when I subscribe to
someone when I'm following them I want
to see more of what they like I want
them to also curate the feed for me and
I think that Twitter and Facebook are
doing that and also some ways that are
kind of annoying
but I would like bet to happen more and
I think we would see communities being
stronger on YouTube if it was that way
instead of YouTube going well
technically Michael like this veritasium
video but people are way more likely to
click on carpool karaoke so I don't even
care who they are just given that not
saying anything against carpool karaoke
that is a extremely important part of
our society what it means to be a human
on earth you know but I'll say it sucks
but uh yeah but a lot of people would
disagree with you and they should be
able to see as much of that as they want
yes and I think even people who don't
think they like it should still be
really aware of it because it's such an
important thing
and such an influential thing but yeah I
just wished that like new channels I
discover and that I subscribe to I wish
that my subscribers found out about that
because especially in the education
community a rising tide floats all boats
if you watch a video from number file
you're just more likely to want to watch
an episode from me
whether it be on Vsauce 1 or ding it's
not it's not competitive in the way that
traditional TV was where it's like well
if you tuned in to that show it means
you're not watching mine because they
both air at the same time so helping
each other out through collaborations
takes a lot of work but just through
engaging commenting on their videos
liking their videos subscribing to them
whatever that I would love to see become
easier and more powerful
you